so you think the 21st century will be
remembered
for the big leaps in biology and
understanding and
alleviation of biology if you look at
the path
between discovery and therapeutics it's
been on the order of 50 years
it's been shortened to 40 30 20 and now
it's on the order of 10 years
but the huge number of technologies that
are
going on right now for discovery will
result
undoubtedly in the most dramatic
manipulation of human biology
that we've ever seen in the history of
humanity in the next few years
do you think we might be able to cure
some of the disease that we started this
conversation with
absolutely absolutely it's it's only a
matter of time
basically the complexity is enormous and
i don't want to underestimate the
complexity
but the number of insides is
unprecedented
and the ability to manipulate is
unprecedented and the ability to deliver
these small molecules and other
non-traditional medicine perturbations
there's a lot of sort of new gen there's
a new generation
of perturbations that you can use at the
dna level at the rna level
at the you know microrna level uh the
genomic level there's
there's a battery of new generations of
perturbations
if you couple that with cell type
identifiers
that can basically sense when you are in
the right cell based on the specific
combination and then
turn on that intervention for that cell
you can now think of combinatorial
interventions
where you can basically sort of feed a
synthetic biology construct to someone
that will basically do different things
in different cells
so basically for cancer this is one of
the therapeutics that our collaborator
ron weiss is using
to basically start sort of engineering
these circuits that will use micrornas
sensors of the environment to sort of
know if you're in a tumor cell
or if you're in an immune cell or if
you're in stromal cells and so forth
and basically turn on particular
interventions there you can sort of
create constructs that are tuned to only
the liver cells or only the heart cells
or only the
you know you know brain cells and then
have these new generations of
therapeutics coupled with this immense
amount of knowledge
on the sort of which targets to choose
and what biological processes to measure
and how to intervene my view is that
disease
is going to be fundamentally altered and
alleviated
as we go forward
you